Jeremy Renner's snow plow accident was
shocking to say the least — and now
the star himself has given fans
an update about his condition.
Renner took to Instagram on Tuesday, January
3rd, to offer up his very first message to
the public since his serious snow plow
accident. The star has been described
as being in "critical but stable" condition
following an accident involving a snow plow
on January 1st. Police officials say Renner
was near Mt. Rose Highway in Reno, Nevada,
when the accident occurred, and that he
suffered a serious injury to his chest.
"As Mr. Renner always does on those private
roads, he was being a great neighbor and he
was plowing those roads for his neighbors,
because, as I say, they had three feet."
It was subsequently reported that
Renner underwent surgery for blunt
chest trauma and orthopedic injuries. A
representative sent out a statement, saying:
"Jeremy's family would like to express
their gratitude to the incredible doctors
and nurses looking after him [...] They
are also tremendously overwhelmed and
appreciative of the outpouring of
love and support from his fans."
While things have appeared to be proceeding
smoothly with Renner's treatment and the start
of his recovery, many fans have nonetheless
been anxious to hear more about how the star
is doing. Thankfully, it now seems that
the actor has recovered enough to manage a
reassuring personal update on his own wellbeing,
as well as a heartfelt thank you to everyone via
social media. This has prompted a deluge of
support in the comments on his Instagram page.
In the new post, the actor included a
single photo of himself in the hospital,
in which he is severely bruised and hooked up to
medical equipment — nevertheless very
much alive. In a caption, he wrote:
"Thank you all for your kind words. I'm too messed
up now to type. But I send love to you all."
An update from Renner himself has proven to
be a moment of comfort for fans in what has
otherwise been an uneasy and concerning series
of updates regarding the actor's condition. The
post garnered a startling amount of attention,
amassing more than 5,700,000 likes and 230,000
comments within roughly 18 hours of being posted.
While the actor remains in critical condition,
it hopefully won't be too long before fans
get another update about Renner's recovery.
Not long after Renner broke
his silence on the 3rd,
fans started flocking to his post
to show support. One fan commented:
"Happy to see you awake."
Another said:
"Was really worried about you even if we
don't know each other. Get well soon."
Another fan commented:
"Thinking of you every day man, sending
love and prayers to my favorite hero."
Many fans were quick to invoke Renner's role as
Hawkeye in the MCU in their
well-wishes. As one said:
"Get better Hawkeye, we all
send our love & support."
Many of Renner's colleagues from throughout
the film and entertainment industry also
took the time to comment on the post.
Fellow Marvel star Chris Pratt said:
"Continued prayers your way brutha."
Meanwhile, Vanessa Hudgens wrote:
"Sending so much love [and] healing!"
And actor Tasha Smith declared:
"[You're] a tough mother you know
what and I love you for it all!"
In addition to showing support, many users
and celebrities expressed their happiness that
Renner was well enough to provide his own update.
Celebrity trainer and actor Jason Walsh posted:
"Damn brother I was really worried
about you. Good to see your face."
And Renner's Tag co-star Isla Fisher commented:
"Phew! I'm so happy you made this post. Sending
you so much love and healing energy. We love you."